2021 was a rough year
but 2022 is about to get a whole lot
better here are 22 reasons why starting
off the mrna technology that was used to
develop the vaccines is going to get way
more useful next year most people don't
know that the scientists at moderna had
actually been working on mrna since 2010
and they weren't planning on building a
business around pandemic prevention
instead the original goal of the company
was to create a vaccine for cancer it
was seen as a long shot and they were
mocked by the press and called the next
theranose this obviously looks
ridiculous in hindsight but mrna was
largely an untested technology at the
time so it seemed like it might not have
an impact well the skeptics were wrong
and now it's clear that mrna is an
incredibly important biological tool
over the past two years scientists have
flocked to the industry billions of
dollars have flowed into companies and
now people are talking about a vaccine
for hiv but mrna isn't the only biotech
breakthrough we should be tracking in
2022 machine learning and ai are finally
starting to prove useful to biologists
the protein folding problem has been
seen as the mount everest of biology for
nearly 50 years and for good reason
proteins are incredibly important to all
aspects of biological life when you
digest food flex your muscles or even
just breathe some air your proteins are
hard at work understanding how these
proteins are built up from amino acids
will speed up the entire biotechnology
industry and just last year we had a
major breakthrough on the protein
folding problem google's deepmind team
released alpha fold 2 which beat out
every other protein folding method that
had ever been tried before then they
open sourced the project effectively
letting the entire scientific community
use this new technology for free the
story doesn't end here though a new
company called isomorphic labs just spun
out of deepmind to focus on ai-driven
biotech research specifically so there's
clearly a big opportunity here now this
whole ai driven biotech thing is pretty
new still and we're unlikely to see real
products come out of this research next
year but ai will definitely have other
meaningful impacts in 2022 we've been
talking about self-driving cars for
nearly a decade now but i think next
year is going to be the start of a real
turning point tesla is rolling out new
versions of the full self-driving beta
every few weeks now cruz is now offering
driverless taxi services in san
francisco on a limited basis and comma
ai shipped the comma-3 aftermarket unit
which adds self-driving capabilities to
normal commuter cars these are just
three of the major players in
self-driving and they are all taking
radically different approaches it's hard
to definitively say which company will
deliver the best self-driving experience
in 2022 but i think we can be confident
that the number of people who have
actually ridden in a self-driving car is
going to skyrocket and a lot of the
technology that's used in self-driving
cars will also be used to speed up
deliveries starship technologies has
already completed over 1 million
deliveries using small self-driving
sidewalk robots and pretty much every
self-driving car company is thinking
about how they can compete in the
fast-growing delivery market the past
few years have led to a massive shift
towards on-demand delivery and
self-driving cars are a logical way to
increase access to delivery services
more and more it looks like fully
self-driving cars are going to be
extremely expensive so it's going to be
critical to get the most value out of
them by using each car essentially 24 7.
now robots are easy to get excited about
we've all seen them in science fiction
movies and can easily visualize the
benefits to our daily lives but there's
another side to ai that will be
incredibly impactful even if it's a lot
less exciting instead of one big
breakthrough in robotics or ai that
changes everything sometimes it's the
small optimizations that add up to big
impacts some people call this area
boring ai and it's basically just the
automation processes that happen across
our entire economy here's an example
imagine your average mid-sized company
every year they process a hundred
thousand pages of documents and don't
really think anything of it it only
takes three minutes of employee time to
process a single document but depending
on what they pay their employees that
can add up to hundreds of thousands of
dollars each year and no one likes doing
these jobs boring ai helps automate
everyday tasks shaving off a few minutes
every day it's not as flashy as a chrome
robot but it makes everything just a
little bit more efficient and can add up
pretty quickly remote work will also
make us more efficient and looks like
it's here to stay at least for some jobs
there's obviously some drawbacks to
remote work but there's a lot to like
about it everyone hates long commute
times and perhaps most importantly
remote work has let people disentangle
their jobs from their living
arrangements it's now entirely possible
to get a great job at a company in a
major city and then move to a cheaper
city hours away or even halfway around
the world there are obviously going to
be challenges here as remote workers
adjust to competition in a global
workforce but there could be some big
wins most importantly we're going to
learn a lot about remote work in 2022 we
will finally have several years of data
to analyze and be able to understand the
long-term effects of this change in the
way we work remote work has led us to
spend more time in front of screens and
that's created a major trend around the
metaverse zuckerberg really believes
that we are only a few years away from
people spending hours every day in
virtual worlds this year he launched
horizon workrooms to enable remote
workers to talk to each other in a
virtual environment early reviews have
been surprisingly good so i think we'll
see more of this in 2022 zuck's big plan
for the metaverse will take years to
fully roll out but i'm sure that the
metaverse will be a central topic of
many keynotes next year one interesting
development on the metaverse side is
specifically in vr i think that whether
or not you like zuck it's exciting to
see so much money get poured into
virtual reality development even if no
one winds up using whatever metaverse
product zuck releases just the fact that
he will have spent billions of dollars
on vr will enable some really cool
things it's totally possible that we
wind up seeing a bifurcation in the
metaverse with zuck's version being
completely different from the open
source crypto native version but even in
that scenario i think everyone benefits
from new investment in vr if the team at
meta can develop a vr headset that's
lightweight high resolution low latency
and reliable that's a win for everyone
and virtual reality is already
accelerating this chart blew my mind
when i saw it oculus actually outsold
the xbox this year at first i thought
that was just because of supply
constraints but oculus actually sold
more units in 2021 than the xbox has in
any of the past five years and look at
the growth rate it's not going to be
enough to just have good vr headsets
though we're eventually going to need
faster internet to support streaming
content to these headsets and that's
where 5g comes in this is an interesting
one because on a day-to-day basis it
might not seem all that relevant current
4g speeds feel plenty fast and as long
as you can stream hd video reliably what
else could you want but as vr and ar
become more essential in everyday life
streaming content is going to require a
lot more bandwidth we should see
american 5g break 100 million users in
2022 or about 1 3 of all cell phones
that's probably enough of a critical
mass to start developing apps and
services that require 5g to work well we
might see certain existing technologies
get better like video game streaming but
my hope is that we see entirely new apps
emerge one particularly interesting area
is ai generated content as the number of
virtual worlds proliferates and more and
more of our daily life is spent online
the demand for content will continue to
grow the internet has enabled micro
communities to flourish and ai could
create even more bespoke experiences gpt
3 has made incredible progress in text
generation and there are already some
apps that use ai to create role-playing
game scenarios these are still very
rough around the edges though but
hopefully next year we'll see a new game
experience that leverages ai to deliver
truly unique storytelling and while
we're on the topic of uniqueness we have
to talk about nft gaming 2021 was
dominated by nfts so 2022 is a bit of a
make or break year in my opinion if
everyone who's working on nfts can
deliver something meaningful beyond just
price spikes i think the conversation
will start to change dramatically gaming
is one place where nfts could make a lot
of sense after all the gaming industry
has already shifted to a free-to-play
model where the majority of revenue
comes from cosmetic items nfts are a
perfect fit for things like fortnite
skins but it's still an open question as
to how these unique gaming items will
actually integrate into various games
the common example of interoperability
is taking your fortnight skin into
minecraft and vice versa but what if the
developers of these games can't come to
an agreement and just don't want to
integrate all of a sudden we're gonna
need entirely new games well new nft
based games are being developed and i
think 2022 will see the first set of
actual reviews pour in if the games are
great i think it will be a huge win for
the mft community broadly if they suck
we could wind up with a bit of an nft
winter and this same logic applies to
web3 broadly crypto got a bit of a
makeover this year with the new buzzword
web 3. it's a hugely controversial topic
with tons of skeptics on every side of
the issue the general idea is that by
rebuilding the basic infrastructure of
the internet using blockchains apps and
services can be more open reliable and
equitable it's a promising idea and one
that i think should be taken seriously
but usage of web 3 technologies is still
extremely low in 2022 we should be
better equipped to answer the question
of where web 3 is going if we see tens
of millions of people using web3 tools
on a daily basis for something other
than just day trading there should be a
lot less skepticism part of what drives
so many people crazy about web 3 and
crypto in general is all of the scams
associated with it it's still so easy to
lose passwords to crypto holdings and
never be able to recover the money there
are also tons of scammers constantly
trying to steal whatever they can from
people who are new to crypto and even
when everyone is behaving honorably
crypto projects often drop in value very
quickly i think we're going to see a
much bigger focus on fraud prevention in
2022 if the crypto community wants
adoption to continue someone is going to
have to fund the tools and educational
materials to help people stay safe when
interacting with web 3. stable coins
could help here in some ways there's
still an overwhelming focus in the
crypto community on getting rich quick i
don't mean to discredit any of the
incredible programmers working hard to
just build cool technology but go and
search youtube for any crypto related
topic and you will see that most of the
attention is on prices if stablecoins go
mainstream we might be able to shift the
industry away from get rich quick
schemes and demonstrate some actual
value critics of web3 and crypto always
say there are no real use cases but
that's never really been true moving
money across borders affordably has
always been difficult and crypto really
is well suited to solve that problem
overall crypto is going to finally start
solving the problems that everyone has
been pointing to for years these are
going to come down using web3 tools is
going to get safer and even the carbon
footprint will shrink as proof of stake
rolls out and moving towards a net zero
economy is definitely going to be a
bigger trend in 2022. already 59
countries which account for over half of
the world's greenhouse gas emissions
have committed to cutting net emissions
down to zero by 2050 or earlier now 30
years is a long timeline but as they say
the journey of a thousand miles begins
with a single step and governments are
already taking action to reach their net
zero targets the us canada and 18 other
countries recently agreed to stop
financing fossil fuel projects abroad by
the end of 2022. this agreement works
out to 18 billion leaving the fossil
fuel industry every year that money was
basically acting as a massive subsidy
for the internal combustion engine and
in 2022 we're going to see electric
vehicle sales hit a new record 2021
already saw a massive 88 increase over
2020 and there's really no signs of that
slowing down almost every major
automaker has announced that they will
be transitioning from internal
combustion engine cars to
battery-powered evs and kelly blue book
estimates that by the end of 2022 there
will be more than 100 different ev
models available on the market electric
options are available for any lifestyle
now they're getting easier and easier to
charge and most importantly they're
getting a lot cheaper the price of
lithium-ion batteries hit a record low
in 2021 and is estimated to continue
dropping over the next four years and
the electricity that flows into these
batteries is getting greener as well
there isn't all that much benefit to
driving an electric vehicle if the
electricity that charges it comes from a
coal plant but fortunately renewable
energy is growing as a percentage of
total energy production and the growth
isn't small in 2022 renewable energy
sources which include wind solar hydro
biomass and geothermal energy will be
the second largest source of u.s energy
generation growing 10 from 2021 levels
carbon capture is also going to become
more widespread and there's even
progress being made in fusion energy now
there are also efforts underway to make
supply chains more environmentally
friendly cargo ships collectively
release 1 billion metric tons of carbon
dioxide into the atmosphere each year
that's about as much as all of the u.s
coal-fired power plants combined this is
because most ships run on a highly
energy dense oil called bunker fuel
fortunately there are a number of
initiatives underway to reduce emissions
container ships that use liquid natural
gas are already in use and
methanol-powered ships are in the works
there are even some crazy attempts to
add giant inflatable sails to the
container ships although who knows where
that will go perhaps most promising is
the potential for building
nuclear-powered container ships
nuclear-powered aircraft carriers have
been working flawlessly for decades now
so we know it can work regardless of the
specific technologies 2022 needs to be a
year where supply chains get a lot more
efficient as we saw all through 2021 our
supply chains are remarkably brittle and
can jam up when subjected to unexpected
stress americans are buying more
physical goods than ever before and that
trend doesn't seem to be slowing down so
making sure that our supply chains are
well thought out and resilient will be
key in 2022 but moving things around on
earth can be a bit boring it's way more
exciting to talk about moving things to
space so we have to talk about spacex's
launch calendar elon is planning 36
different launches in 2022 that's three
per month almost one every week and
that's going to have a pretty dramatic
impact on the industry we will likely
see the first orbital launch of starship
by february the plan is for starship to
launch via the super heavy booster from
boca chica it will complete about half
an orbit before splashing down in the
pacific ocean near hawaii and throughout
next year spacex plans to conduct 12
different starship test launches which
will inform the decision to start
carrying real payloads into space
starship is going to dramatically change
the economics of getting to space and we
will likely see payload costs decrease
significantly once the starship program
gets the green light the current market
for rocket launches is actually pretty
small but the market for doing
interesting things in space is nearly
limitless entirely new industries are
going to start popping up that take
advantage of this lower cost to get to
space we're already seeing this with
startups like varda which aims to
manufacture sensitive materials in space
a business that really can't exist
without dirt cheap launch costs 2022 is
going to see a lot more competition
between various space companies but it
won't stop there international
competition in space is going to become
a much hotter topic in 2022 china is
about to complete a new space station in
low earth orbit which will obviously put
pressure on other countries to develop
more aggressive space plans the
decommissioning of old satellites has
also become a major international issue
as space junk continues to threaten the
iss hopefully the result of all this
competition is just more funding for
space-related programs there is so much
to explore in our solar system and we're
clearly just getting started so here's
to a great 2022. happy new year and i'll
see you in the next one